Speaker 1: There is a new story involving Secret
Service text messages related to the Trump riots
that has now gone viral and exploded. I'm going
to tell you what's going on. And remember,
just because text messages have been erased
doesn't mean they aren't retrievable. And indeed,
the latest news is that the text messages, despite
being deleted, are going to be retrieved. So let's
jump into the story. CNBC Report January 6th Panel
Subpoenas Secret Service for Erased Texts. The
House committee investigating the U.S. Capitol
attack subpoenaed the Secret Service for text
messages. Agents reportedly deleted right around
January six, 2021, the date of the Trump riots.
Committee Chairman Bennie Thompson said in
a statement The committee understands the
messages had been erased. Thompson outlined an
aggressive timeline for the production of the
documents by Tuesday. That's tomorrow. And
I'll tell you in a moment whether they are
going to have the text messages by that date,
The Guardian reports. January 6th Committee
to receive deleted Secret Service texts. According
to Democrat agency's account of how texts
sent on Capitol attack and day before were lost
has shifted several times. When you get different
explanations for the same occurrence,
it's not proof that someone is lying,
but it's at least a suggestion that you should
be looking into. What the hell is going on?
Deleted Secret Service text sent on January six,
the day of the insurrection at the US Capitol
will be released by Tuesday to the House
committee. You can imagine how shocked we were
to get the letter from the Department of Homeland
Security Inspector General saying he'd been trying
to get this information and they had in fact been
deleted after he asked for them, said Zoe Lofgren
to ABC's This Week. We need all the text to get
the full picture. This is the interesting part the
secret services account about how text messages
from the day before and the day of the Capitol
attack were a race has shifted several times.
At one point, the explanation from the Secret
Service for the lost texts was because of software
upgrades, according to the inspector general.
At another point, the explanation
was because of device replacements.
The inspector general also said that though
the Secret Service opted to have his office do
a review of the agency's response to the Capitol
attack in lieu of conducting after action reports.
It then stonewalled the review by slow walking
production materials. There were claims during the
Trump administration that even the Secret Service,
which is widely I don't know if widely considered
but widely expected to be an apolitical
organization involved only in protecting
individuals in positions of power, including
the president, their family and others,
even though that's the idea. The allegations
during the Trump presidency were that even Secret
Service had turned political and that there were
essentially Trump hacks within Secret Service,
maybe not at the highest levels, but at medium
and agent levels. If indeed that was the case,
it would make sense that they would all of
a sudden be wanting to be very cloudy about
what took place on January 5th, on January six,
particularly now in light of Cassidy Hutchinson's
claims before the committee that Trump tried to
get Secret Service to take them to the Capitol for
the riot that Trump tried to commandeer a vehicle,
that Trump lunged at a Secret Service agent,
and on and on and on. So the circumstantial case
would give us a number of reasons to suspect why
the Secret Service might just just not have
accidentally deleted the exact test texts that
were requested as of this morning. Deleted Secret
Service texts to be sent to January six committee
by Tuesday tomorrow. So it does appear as though
the Secret Service texts will be turned over and
on Thursday night is what is, at least for now,
considered to be the last January six hearing.
We will see what role these text messages play
that you really can't make this stuff up. Now,
remember, as we are learning here, deleted
and retrievable are. Two different things.
And if you zoom out for a moment and think about
January five, January 6th. Trump's daily visitor
and call log has that very suspicious seven
hour gap talked about that months ago Mike Pence
didn't want to get into the car with Secret
Service when the rioters were getting into
the House, the Capitol, and they were chanting,
hang Mike Pence and a gallows had been built.
Pence was hesitant to get into the car with Secret
Service. Why exactly? We don't know. And now we
have the allegation and it seems to be proven
that Secret Service texts were deleted. Look at
the pattern. Extraordinarily odd. Extraordinarily
bizarre. And in the next 72 to 96 hours, we may
have more insights into exactly what is in those
text messages. Let me know what you expect. Find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. We'll take a quick
break and be right back. We are going to be doing
the next David Pakman show live town hall
next Tuesday, July 26th. It is going to be 6
p.m. Eastern time, 3 p.m. Pacific. It will be on
the Pacman Live YouTube channel like we've been
doing recently. I would love for you
to call in. Everyone is welcome to do
so. Make sure you subscribe to at YouTube.com
slash pacman live. More info forthcoming but
looking forward to it. Will take all questions for
about an hour and a half and that will be that.
Also remember you can sign up at join pacman dot
com The David Pakman Show. Viewer and listener
supported. You can use the coupon code big voting
22 to get a discount at join pacman dot com